- [Main Speaker] Every country
on this planet has a story
about its founding,
whether it's about a group of rebels
trampling the global superpower.
- [Man] Mohandas Karamchand Gandhi.
- [Main Speaker] Or, a passivist
delivering independence
for the second largest
country on the planet.
- [Man] And, he's been called
the most powerful man of the 20th century.
- Or, some dude pulling
out a sword from a rock.
Usually, somewhat fabricated
and polished ideas
of where the country came
from, what it stands for.
- [All] Hail King Arthur.
Long live the king.
- But, China's story is different.
China's story is a new story
and it is tightly controlled.
(people shouting)
It's a story that is
being used as a weapon,
a weapon to subjugate millions of people,
to eliminate ancient cultures,
to expand China's borders farther
than they've ever pushed before.
It's a founding myth that can't
be challenged within China.
And, it has been so heavily pedaled
and thoroughly implanted
into the Chinese psyche,
that most people believe that
China actually looks like this
and that it has always looked like this,
but China doesn't look like this.
China actually looks a lot more like this,
but only if you look at the
real history, the facts,
and the evidence,
which is something you can't
really do within China.
So, instead, the communist
party has created
and weaponized the myth of
this over the past 70 years
to erase these borders, to build islands,
to threaten neighbors,
and to undertake one of the
largest assimilation projects
in human history.
It's a project that has cost
them trillions of dollars
and has been responsible for countless,
horrific human rights violations,
all in the name of preserving
a pretend version of history.
A version that China believes
will keep the communist party in power
and make China the richest,
most powerful country on Earth.
And, what's scary is it just might work.
- [Narrator 2] This is
the history of the CCP.
- [Narrator 3] Xi Jinping
does not want you to know.
- Several mosques have been destroyed
in China's far Western region of Xinjiang.
- [Woman] Xinjiang, Xinjiang.
- [Narrator 2] One of
Xinjiang's holiest sites...
- Is not only cracking down on Muslims,
but on other religions as well.
- [Female Reporter] One
of the most common sites
is the Chinese leaders' smiling face.
- One of the world's most
ambitious construction projects
is going on in secret.
- Will not let foreign journalists
visit those islands in
the South China Sea.
(man speaking in Chinese)
- Okay, pause for a second.
I need to thank today's sponsor,
because that's how I am
able to make these videos.
Thank you, NordVPN,
who is a longtime
supporter of this channel.
A VPN is a really cool tool that allows me
to connect to the internet
through a different country.
This is cool, because, not
only can I like stream Netflix,
like that's not available in my country,
but is available in like the UK,
but also I've been traveling lately.
And, when I'm in like
Korea, which I just was,
and I try to connect to my Gmail
or a bunch of other things
that I'm logged into,
all of these accounts freak out,
because they're like someone in Korea
is trying to hack into your email
and I'm like, no, they're not, it's me.
So, I just now reroute
my connection to the US
and my Gmail and everything is happy.
That is one reason I use Nord VPN,
but Nord VPN has become this way bigger
threat protection tool.
It has all these great
features like blocking malware
or malicious ad trackers.
It generates strong passwords for you.
It's just like a super useful tool.
And, all of this is
incredibly easy to use.
It's all one click away, super
easy, super user friendly.
There's a reason why NordVPN
is like the leading VPN out there.
Right now, they're having a
30 day money back guarantee.
And, if you go to the
link in my description,
which is NordVPN.com/JohnnyHarris,
you can get an exclusive NordVPN deal
plus one month for free
to just check it out.
Using that link helps
support this channel too.
So, do us both a favor, go
click it, go check it out,
and with the internet
from around the world
and be safer about it.
Thank you NordVPN for
supporting this channel,
for supporting this video.
Now, let's dive into this kind of heavy
but important story about China.
Okay, before we dive in,
I wanna just make it clear
that I'm aware that all
countries do this thing,
this thing of weaponizing their history
to make themselves look good
and totally justify terrible things.
- [Inigo] You seem a decent
fellow. I hate to kill you.
- This video is about China.
- [Westley] You seem a decent
fellow. And, I hate to die.
- So, I keep talking about
this Chinese narrative,
this Chinese myth,
what is it?
Well, you could hear me talk about it
or we could go right to the horse's mouth
and listen to this guy, Xi Jinping,
who's probably the best
salesman for the Chinese story.
Here, he is giving a speech
where he starts out with
his boldest claim of all
that China is this 5,000
year old civilization.
- [Female Interpreter] With a history
of more than 5,000 years,
our nation created a
splendid civilization.
- But, according to his story, in 1840,
outsider Europeans came in
and tore apart his unified country
- [Female Interpreter] A China
was plunged into the darkness
of domestic turmoil
and foreign aggression.
- And, now, China is fighting back.
- [Female Interpreter] We
must be ready to fight,
build our ability,
and keep striving to secure
new victories in this struggle.
- So, the modern communist party of China
is engaged in a project to
restore the greatness of China,
to make China great again.
Okay, right,
but this is just a political speech.
Why do we care
if this guy's romanticizing
the history a little bit?
It doesn't really matter, right?
No, actually, it does matter.
- Pam, take a chill pill.
- What I wanna show you is that Xi Jinping
and the communist party use this story
to justify terrible things,
mass assimilation of
people to be controlled
by the central government of Beijing.
So, to do this, let me
just quickly go back,
and we can do a time lapse
of this region of Asia
and what it looked like over
the past few thousand years
to sort of fact check Xi Jinping.
- [Male Narrator] Here is China,
cradle of civilization in Asia.
- What we think of as Chinese culture
or Chinese civilization
has indeed been around
for thousands of years.
It was born here along the Yangtze River
where a lot of the language,
political systems, writing,
art,
all of the traditions sort of originated.
But, from there, the idea of
a contiguous unified China
becomes kind of a myth.
I'm gonna put the modern
borders of China on this map,
so that you can see what
really is happening here.
Over thousands of years,
if you were to look at this territory,
you would see all sorts
of land configurations.
Looking at this,
you can see that China goes
from these periods of unity
to periods of total division.
Over the past several thousand years,
China has gone from a
bunch of divided kingdoms
to periods of total unity
where lots of good things happened,
technology, agriculture, unity, power.
During times of division,
bad things happened.
The country was in chaos,
there was destruction, there
was war, there was lawlessness.
And, this just keeps on
happening for thousands of years,
a seemingly endless cycle
of unity and then division.
Xi Jinping is very right
that out of this region,
during some of these unified periods,
came like real serious advancements
in shipping, and math,
and like gun powder,
and all of these things
that like have informed
how we've all developed as a world.
This part of Eastern Asia was
definitely on the forefront,
but it was never one contiguous China
for thousands of years.
And, the upshot was very clear.
Unity meant prosperity, and technology,
and all these good things.
And, disunity equals chaos and bad things.
Okay, so it's now the 1700s,
and, over in Europe,
the new fad is imperialism.
- Imperialism.
- [Man 2] Imperialism.
- [Man 3] Right, yeah.
- As European countries
who are looking for more land
so that they can expand their borders,
send their armies, and
everyone's doing it.
It's the French, it's the British,
it's the Spanish,
it's even the Japanese are starting
to get on board with this.
And, over here, in today
what we call China,
they had once again slipped into a period
of serious disunity.
They were divided, but this time it came
with an extra dose of humiliation.
- [Narrator 3] It's not for nothing
that the period stretching
around a hundred years
from the 1840s to the 1940s
is known as China's
century of humiliation.
- This era of disunity in
China came from outsiders.
You can see this political cartoon,
all of these barbarians at the door,
vying to carve up and slice
up China for their own profit.
China was once again in the dumps,
and it was here,
while European and Japanese powers
were dividing up their land,
that China learned its
second crucial lesson,
not just that unity is better,
but that if you want to survive
in this brave new world,
you have to play by the new rules.
And, those rules were
very clearly laid out by
these European empires,
defined borders, a patriotic agenda,
assimilating other
cultures into their own.
This was the playbook the
Europeans were playing by
and it was working.
Okay, so fast forward now.
It's like the 1900s.
It's the beginning of
the communist revolution
that would eventually
envelop this entire country.
The communist leaders were
small still at this point.
And, they used this century
of humiliation, and division,
as well as this general lesson
of unity equals prosperity,
to rally the people for a new cause.
The revolutionaries like
we've been sliced up
and divided by all of
these foreign powers.
And, when we're divided, we fail,
remember, exhibit A, B, and C.
So, these communist leaders went off
and created this grand
vision of a united China.
A story that China had
actually always been united.
They framed it in terms
of this former glory
of what China used to be,
what it was before the outsiders came in,
a grandiose vision of the past
that never really existed.
I mean, again, this sounds
pretty darn familiar.
- We will make America
strong again, proud again,
safe again, great again.
- And, that became the grand plan
of the communist revolution in China,
to make China United again,
despite the fact that China
had never really been fully united,
not like this,
but the story, this vision,
was a potent rallying cry.
China would never be cut
up again, never humiliated.
It would have defined borders
ethnic purity, cultural assimilation.
And, so for the last 70 years,
that's the great project that China
and the communist party
have been undertaking,
creating their own great empire,
controlled by a central authority.
This project has coincided
with China getting rich,
pulling a hundred million
people out of poverty,
and becoming a global superpower
all just in a few decades.
All of this has given the government
a lot of resources with which
to execute their project
of forcefully uniting a swath of land
that isn't and has never been united.
And, I wanna show you
what that looks like.
- The issue of China ruling
over autonomous regions
is controversial.
So, what are China's autonomous regions?
And, are they really all that autonomous?
- This is the map that most people
are familiar with when
they think of China.
But, this outline doesn't
tell you the whole story,
because nearly half of this
land is considered autonomous,
super jargony term.
What does that even mean?
There are over 56 ethnicities in China.
Most of them concentrated
far away from Beijing,
like over here in Tibet,
or over here in Xinjiang.
When those communist leaders
were setting up their
new unified China empire,
they kind of admitted like, okay,
there are a lot of
cultures, and languages,
and identities within this country,
we should let these
people govern themselves.
Not entirely, of course.
They'd still have to answer to
Beijing with certain things,
but they would have
autonomy, autonomous regions,
but many of these semi autonomous
regions, like Xinjiang,
Tibet, and southern Mongolia,
these places were never originally a part
of any conception of China.
They were forcefully absorbed
by the Chinese communist party
during its nation building project
like in the past 70 years.
Okay, let's get specific here.
Xinjiang is a region that
is very far from Beijing,
not just geographically,
but also culturally.
It is a huge region,
roughly the size of Alaska,
has 25 million people,
and half of those people
identify as Uyghur
which are mostly Muslims who
are from a Turkic descent
not like a Han Chinese descent.
They come from a different culture.
The street signs are not
in any Chinese language.
They're in like the
Uyghur Turkic language.
The architecture looks a lot
more at home in like Istanbul
than it does in Beijing.
And, five times a day,
the streets fill with the sound of prayer.
Xinjiang was an independent
Republic twice before,
but eventually it was overthrown by China.
Eight years after China grabbed Xinjiang,
the Chinese government did the same thing
to an even more remote region
at the highest plateau
in the world, Tibet.
They annexed this place
that is three times the size of Texas.
It has its own very distinct
language, culture, identity,
and does not identify
or connect with Beijing.
And, back in the day, again,
when China wasn't rich and powerful,
they couldn't really wrangle these regions
until suddenly they got rich really fast.
- [Female Reporter 2] Second in GDP,
only to the United States.
- And, for the past 30 to 40 years,
China has been pouring money
and people into these two regions
to make them more like China.
It's kind of like the geopolitical version
of gentrification.
It's basically where non-Chinese societies
are subsumed by societal
norms of Han Chinese culture,
because of a bunch of
militarization and money.
So, in Tibet, you see this
in the Tibetan schools
that are only teaching in Mandarin
not in the traditional Tibetan language
or you see it in Xinjiang,
where the mosques are torn down
for being too Islamic,
and are rebuilt in
traditional Chinese styles.
Oh, and it starts to get a lot worse.
In Xinjiang, the Uyghurs
are literally taken away
by the millions
and forced into concentration camps
where they're supposedly
forcibly taught Chinese values.
The government is involved
in a mass sterilization project
where they are forcibly inserting IUDs
and other birth control forms
to basically run them into extinction.
And, not just like 10 people,
like millions of people.
China originally gave
these people autonomy,
because they recognized that
they had their own culture
and they wanted to retain it.
But, now, they've totally
thrown that deal out the window.
The way this presents most
commonly in these regions
is just the presence
of military and police.
There are checkpoints everywhere.
There's restricted movement,
there's constant surveillance.
And, every year that
passes by becomes harder.
These people resist, they fight back.
They commit acts of terror.
And, in response, China sends
more military, more police,
and more surveillance equipment.
In 2018, China spent $10
billion in security in Xinjiang.
That's almost double the year before
and 10 times as much as
it was 10 years previous.
3 billion of those dollars go
into these reeducation camps.
That's four times more
than the previous year.
I mean, it's ramping up.
They're pouring money into these regions.
Per person, China spends 3,100
Yuan on security in Tibet,
2,400 in Xinjiang,
per person.
Compare that to the national
average of 763 Yuan per person
and you can see that every
single person in these regions
is worth a lot more in terms of the cost
of making them assimilate.
So, the question is why?
Why is China doing this?
Why are they investing so much money
into occupying and forcibly
assimilating these people?
Well, there are several geopolitical
and economic reasons why
the communist party wants to do this.
First off, the resources.
Xinjiang produces 87% of the
country's cotton, for example.
And, when it comes to Tibet,
you can see that they provide a buffer
between China and India.
Tibet also has the largest
fresh water supply in the world,
given where they are, so high up.
China also uses these regions
as a part of their big
infrastructure initiative,
the belt and road initiative.
They use infrastructure
to connect these regions
to continue to fortify their
economic standing in the world.
But, I believe the real
reason is this myth,
this myth of a united China,
because a United China is a strong China.
A divided China is a chaotic China.
This has been the
rallying cry for 70 years,
but it's not just assimilation
within their borders.
This myth has also fueled and justified
China's adventures in expansion elsewhere.
- [Male Reporter] This
is the South China Sea.
- China says it will fight to the very end
to prevent Taiwan from
being declared independent.
- [Male Reporter 2] The
former British colony
is being smashed into submissions.
- So, now you have China building islands
in the South China Sea
claiming that this entire
ocean belongs to them.
Oh, that's just China reclaiming
what was rightfully theirs,
because, after all,
this ocean's been theirs for 5,000 years,
they're just reclaiming it.
Violating its promise to let
Hong Kong stay independent
and absorbing it into
China piece by piece,
oh, that's just China
restoring sovereignty
over these islands
that Britain stole in like the 1800s.
How about an invasion of
Taiwan to unite it forcibly
with China?
All they're doing is restoring
China back to the way it was.
But, again, this was never the case.
This is a story constructed 70 years ago
to unify a country that was
on the brink of collapse.
This story today is weaponized
and used by Xi Jinping
and the communist party
to justify almost everything
that they're doing.
- [Female Interpreter] A Xi
Jin national rejuvenation
will be no walk in the park.
It will take more than drum beating
and the gong clanging to get there.
Everyone of us in the party
must be prepared to work
even harder toward this goal.
- Okay, so to end this, I
just wanna say one last thing,
which is I have no interest
in bashing on China
and Chinese culture.
There is so much beauty
that comes from this region of the world.
And, as I mentioned, every
one of the countries out there
including my own
are guilty of a weaponized history.
The reason I'm concerned
and focused on this
is because this mythical fake
story that China is using.
It can't be fact checked within China.
So, instead, the Chinese government
is able to use this story as a weapon
to justify the oppression of its people,
the grabbing of land,
and, honestly, looking at it,
how it's playing out,
it's just a modern day version
straight out of the old
European imperialistic handbook.